You're probably familiar with many of
the services that are offered by Google.
And if you develop applications
your users likely are too.
Perhaps they need to find a location or
see what's interesting nearby.
They're using Google Maps.
Maybe you want to monetize your apps so
that app usage is rewarded and your
users, they don't have to pay upfront.
Google Ads is your friend.
As well as these, we've got lots of
great APIs for you, storing files in
the cloud with Google Drive,
accessing Goggle Analytics.
Signing into your application,
integrating with Google Fit and
much, much more.
In this course, you'll learn how to
use these services in your apps.
You'll see how easily you have
the power of Google at your fingertips,
allowing you to build better apps.
Before you can get started, let's take a
look at getting the tools that you need.
You'll be building your apps using
Android Studio, which is available at no
cost to you and can be downloaded
from developer.android.com.
If you want some help in setting it up,
check out the Android Fundamentals
course at the url below.